: warfare season 4 is here and it's a
big one and I don't just mean file size
new maps modes and more are dropping in
so here's everything you need to know
let's talk war zone first since it has
some new modes the first is jailbreak
and it lets everyone waiting in the
gulag even those who are just spectating
to go free and respawn this can happen
randomly during the match second is fire
sale which makes everything at buy
stations 80% off or straight-up free
finally there's war zone Rumble which
pits two teams of 50 players against
each other you'll find new supply
choppers on the map to their non-lethal
themselves but it takes a ton of
firepower to bring one down from the sky
while you're flying around keep an eye
on that damn and that nuke Infinity Ward
is definitely up to something and now
for modern warfare multiplayer is
getting three more Maps and some of them
might look familiar
though Cobb scrapyard is a small map
filled with airplane parts and you may
remember it as scrapyard 4 modern
warfare 2 trench is also a small map
that's because it's made for gunfights
finally there's Bereket promenade it's
meant for ground war but it's actually
pulled right out of the war zone map
modern warfare is also getting three new
modes this season first is one in the
chamber like the name implies this
free-for-all starts you with a pistol
with a single bullet take out an
opponent to earn another one all or
nothing is another free-for-all mode
that gives you just a pistol and a
throwing knife
finally there's team defender which is
basically capture the flag and now for
that file size if you're playing on ps4
it's 32 point 5 gigs on Xbox one it's 44
point 3 on PC it's 45 if you have both
modern warfare and war zone or 39.6 if
you only have warzone some players are
reporting even bigger file sizes but
Activision says that's a bug in any case
the update will actually only take up 4
gigs on your hard drive once it's
installed so you can be grateful for
that and you can be grateful for more
Call of Duty coverage from GameSpot
we'll always be here to tell you about
the new stuff so stay tuned
[Music]
you
[Music]